une semaine après les catholiques et les
protestants les chrétiens orthodoxes
fête ce dimanche pâques dans un contexte
de confinement les autorités les ont
globalement invités à rester chez eux
pour limiter la propagation du
coronavirus c'est le cas en russie
à la demande du chef du patriarcat de
moscou les cérémonies pascales se
tiendront le plus souvent à huit clos
dans des églises vides le prin le
patriarcat que
oecuméniques de constantinople en
turquie a également annoncé que les
offices serait fermée au public et
retransmise sur internet
même situation en grèce en serbie ou
encore en egypte